[Musique]
la parole s'est mise à mort lundi puis
cette semaine je vais répondre à une
question du public
d'ailleurs c'est une question qui
revient à chaque année donc je trouvais
que ce téléphone de pouvoir y répondre
et en parler encore parce que plus on
répète plus ça va être connu c'est sur
l'expression de l'été des indiens il ya
beaucoup mieux donc vous voulez savoir
c'est une expression plus approprié que
l'été des indiens pour pouvoir parler
justement de cette période de redoux ou
même de chaleur inhabituelle qui vient
après un des premiers gels de l'automne
vont comprendre un peu que la base de
cette expression le viendrait des
européens qui à l'époque quand il voyait
justement cette période de l'été des
indiens voyez supposément une activité
plus grande dans les communautés
autochtones
d'activité de chasse ou de kayes est
donc je pense que c'est surtout que nos
ancêtres utiliser cette période de
redoux comme une période de pouvoir pour
pouvoir voir accueillir plus à chasser
plus faut comprendre qu'on fait nous
activités en extérieur le beau temps
c'est une bonne raison pour tout le
monde peu importe de quelle nation
revient mais cette expression là quand
même pris beaucoup d'ampleur à un tel
point que même l'utilisent dans d'autres
pays où justement il n'y avait pas les
dix indiens pour pouvoir montrer
l'activité sur la forêt est donc
c'est sûr qu'en cette période on dit on
peut plus rien dire qu'il y en ait pour
qui même l'expression de l'été des
indiens quand ils sont eux-mêmes
d'origine autochtone ça ne les dérange
pas pour certains même le fait de
vouloir transformer l'expression de
l'été des indiens devient une forme d'un
visibilisation des communautés
autochtones donc vous comprendrez que ça
va être discuté de plusieurs angles
différents donc l'invisibilisation on
peut rien y faire on était complètement
absent à pas pour certaines expressions
certains logos certaines représentations
qui ne venaient pas de nous donc c'est
certain que de remplacer les vieux logo
des vieilles expressions par de
nouvelles ça peut vouloir dire que ce
sera plus les autochtones qui seront au
centre de cette expression là mais
cependant c'est peut-être une bonne
chose de pouvoir dire c'était pas cette
représentation l'autre nous communauté
qu'on veut à donc c'est certain que
c'était une partie du discours qui a
mené de l'avant une autre c'est on ne
peut plus rien dire et bien c'est
certain que si vous préférez utiliser
des vieilles les expressions péjoratives
ou même des fois l'utiliser parce
qu'elle est un contexte historique dans
le contexte de la réconciliation c'est
bien de pouvoir l'expliquer aussi
pourquoi on dit l'été des indiens
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est encore
aujourd'hui cette expression là pendant
que d'autres travaillent à la remplacer
par des expressions plus adéquat ou même
des fois juste dire mais moi ce que
j'utilise encore l'été désagréger
terville études mais je sais que ça n'a
rien à voir avec les intérêts d'al aïn
donc ça fait un peu plus long à
expliquer
certaines des suggestions que j'ai
entendu les deux qui me reste le plus
dans l'esprit pour remplacer de l'été
des indiens
c'est l'été de la seconde chance ou le
dernier était donc c'est la dernière
période où il va faire d'où avant que
l'hiver s'installe avant que le froid
vienne et donc c'est une période de
jeu de bon temps de disette des gens
vont peut-être même aller à la plage se
faire griller un peu parce que des fois
des températures peuvent aller jusqu'à
30 degrés celsius donc l'idée de la
seconde chance mais j'aime bien aussi le
rapport avec l'expression d'origine de
l'été des indiens c'est à dire une
activité de chasse et de cueillette
beaucoup plus active dont on pourrait
appeler seuls étaient des chasseurs et
ça a coïncidé avec justement l'activité
qui était remarquée à cette époque
l'heure et ça a permis aussi deux heures
qu'on utilise les uns c'est tout le
parcours
d'explication qui élit avec la relation
des communautés autochtones donc c'est
une suggestion les langues change les
expressions change et c'est correct
parce que je veux dire si on faisait les
mêmes mots on utilisait dans les années
50 ou même au 19e siècle je pense qu'il
y aurait des gens qui seraient pas très
finement de se faire traiter de certains
mots sont extrêmement péjoratif donc la
transformation de l'expression d un
indien ou un indien vers des expressions
beaucoup plus adéquat va mon prix d'une
incorporation justement de 7 contre en
sont là d'existence soit oublié souvent
négligé des communautés autochtones dans
l'histoire et d'une relation qui tend à
représenter mieux les communautés
autochtones dans leur présence
historique au canada au québec aux
états-unis alors c'est ma suggestion
maison je ne choisis pas ce qui est
populaire dans la langue ce qui va
prendre un peu dans d'envol avec avec
les expressions que les gens ont utilisé
de nos jours mais un mes suggestions
pour l'été des indiens c'est l'été de la
seconde chance où ils étaient des
chasseurs alors je vous remercie et
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions c'est toujours extrêmement
apprécié et c'était pas surtout à
partager ses vidéos bonne semaine